the Joe Rogan experience hello Lex you
might be wondering why what I'm wearing
on my face I'm not wondering
no no it's coronavirus time everybody
out there is wearing a mask so I'm
assuming that's what you're wearing on
your face yeah so this is a homemade
mess takes 30 seconds to make 30 seconds
did you time yourself I don't know yeah
Brock can you like cut a cup and like
strap tied on that would work but
there's no yes probably but it probably
there as far as I'm aware there's no
scientific study of how effective bras
are at filtering how effective is that
thing so there it's I'm glad you asked
you this is some part of this and I'll
take this off in a few minutes I just
want one I want to talk about some of
the science into I want to remove some
of the stigma that's around masks so I'm
part of this group of scientists that
have put together a survey paper showing
that masks work and it started as a
movement called masks fall hashtag in
the Czech Republic that essentially one
of the critical components of stopping
the spread of coroner viruses everybody
has to wear masks and the science is
twofold so I mean I need to break this
apart but you're gonna take the mask off
eventually right yeah so let's just take
notice I can hear you cuz there's an
audio it's you can hear that's so much
better
oh yeah nice so like taking a condom off
the before and after so you probably
shouldn't be wearing a mask when you're
doing podcasts definitely not but
everywhere else yes
so when you're going out to the grocery
store each wear a mask everywhere and
that's okay so some some questions do
homemade masks work so there's a
currently a shortage of n95 respirator
masks which should be exclusively used s
PPE personal protective equipment by
healthcare workers okay there's also a
shortage of surgical masks which are
these non Vohland fabric masks
that work very well for the thing I'm
talking about but because there's a
shortage of them we should not be buying
them and should be saving them for
health care workers and then the open
question was whether homemade masks like
the one I just described work to stop as
a filtration mechanism this is the
confusing thing for the individual
centric society they will live in masks
are the most what are they actually
effective for what they're effective for
is to prevent me if I'm infected
asymptomatic from spreading the
infection to you so that's where the
movement of masks for all started which
is your mask protects me my mask
protects you and the idea there is is
not I'm not protecting I'm not creating
a wall from the rest of society I am
contributing to the sort of the bigger
aggregate picture of it by not allowing
the infection to spread so masks is
masks allow you to reduce that
transmission rate to one to below one so
allowing you to decrease the
transmission rate while also long people
to be in public so I mean how long do
you think it's gonna take before
businesses are up and running again
I know Wuhan is back up in business
again but there's a lot of criticism
about that and they're also saying
they're seeing new cases I think the
question I think it can be sooner than
we think if we do the following things
so one I'd hate to linger on this I'd
love to talk to you talk about masks
well it's funny but you're I know for a
fact you're gonna make fun of me just
like I'll make fun of you right back for
loving fanny packs
but just like fanny packs are
exceptionally functional to carry all
the things you need masks will be what
masks are required
yes low the spread of this infection
listen I'm not an anti mask person and
would like one of the things that to do
is you have to start getting governors
so politicians to wear them our
President Trump to wear them well
is the Boris Johnson question right
because that guy not only was he not
wearing masks with you shaking hands and
he was talking about it pretty openly
and now he's in intensive care if he
dies that will be the biggest wake-up
call for everyone yeah I mean I hope he
doesn't die but goddamn people are so
mean over there I don't know his
policies I don't know I don't haven't
been in England in a long time I don't
know how they feel about him but [ __ ]
people some people hate him
does she like saying things like they
would they're hoping he dies they hope
he suffers and dies I've read the
Twitter Andrew Doyle angel Boyle rather
the guy who wrote woke Tatyana McGrath
yeah his he but it was actually his own
personal account he published some of
the tweets that people have written
about you we don't have to put it up
there I don't want to up these people's
signal but it's just so heartless so
yeah that's masks but testing really big
one there's no there's there's three
things masks besides like washing hands
and social distancing all that stuff
masks testing and contact tracing so
contact tracing contests so this is
great let's talk about this first of all
I'm gonna keep would we get it masks
well you don't get it
we don't get have you have you been
wearing masks you know how weird it is
like societally for us it's a weird
stuff to take I don't know what it's
like an open question what does it take
to do that
yeah you know it's weird it's really
weird so you can't see the emotional
expression of the people you can't it
like that there's a strange effect to it
and then the other effect is as a as an
individualistic society you're wearing
the mask not to protect yourself but but
to protect others and that's a weird
thing for us to do we don't I don't
think people are thinking that I think
they think they're protecting themselves
well you can sort of delude them or you
can tell them the truth
ya know the that this I mean there's a
nice positive aspect to this is me
wearing a mask says I care about not
getting you sick yeah it's a really
powerful social signal for when you're
hanging hanging out with people I think
there's so much ignorance going on
though I don't think people weren't
there's a large percentage of people is
my assumption that are wearing that mass
that are not wearing it because they
think they're going to protect other
people they're worried about getting it
yeah and I don't think I mean this is
what the WI Cho and the CDC this is
where I I hate what they're doing with
which is sort of there's truth and that
there is ideas of how the truth will be
misinterpreted by the public and so you
shouldn't tell people the truth so
there's a kind of sense like the wh h o
and CDC have said that masks don't work
for example or they said that we
shouldn't be wearing masks we should you
see them for the health care workers
well we have to be honest about what the
timeline the WH are what they've said
they're wrong about so much of it
they're initially saying they couldn't
transfer it from person to person I mean
this is just in at the beginning of the
year I mean Dan Crenshaw I went over the
timeline of all the things that were
wrong about what the World Health
Organization said on the podcast
yesterday it's terrifying stuff and you
know and obviously newspapers were going
off of that information and they were
printing misleading stuff as well and
the president didn't know nobody knows
it the whole thing is very weird if
you're if you're going based on what
they were saying it didn't look like it
was gonna be nearly as bad as it is and
then everyone has had to make
adjustments I'm actually the one I'm so
I'm I'm so freaked out about the loss of
life and the loss of jobs and how people
are getting SIDS it's it's really weird
that everything about it is weird it's
weird in our lifetime to be a part of
something that's just affecting the
entire world like this but I've gotten a
lot of messages from friends that are
cordoned teamed with their families and
like we've never been closer and that we
realized that we're in this together
because we realized that you know during
these crazy times you you realize what
is important love that silly little word
you were talking about love and
community and friendship like my
neighbors everyone's so nice everyone's
waving now and everyone's like saying hi
and you know talking from over the side
of the yard and how's everything you
guys alright need anything we're right
here there's a lot of this like comfort
and warmth that you know I think
experienced a little bit of that post
9/11 where
people get shocked they get shook up and
then they realize what matters you know
yeah that's one of the things I don't
like about masks is uh it feels like
you're protecting yourself from like
you're removing yourself yeah see
there's that look and what get away from
me dirty people yeah get away from me so
the germaphobe kind of idea that's not
what they are supposed to represent but
that I'm sitting here on the science
that says we have to all wear them and
then thinking like how is that going to
change interactions
[Applause]